el círculo x cuadrada más cuadrada menos
8 x igual a cero y la hipérbola x
cuadrada sobre nueve menos cuadrada
sobre cuatro igual a 1 intersecta al
punto a y b y la ecuación de la tangente
común con pendiente positiva la tangente
como con pendiente positiva al círculo
así como la hipérbola es y primero
enfoquémonos en lo que nos están
preguntando aunque no sé por qué tengo
el presentimiento de que esto nos va a
ocupar varios vídeos pero bueno déjenme
visualizar cómo podemos comenzar a
resolver dicho problema primero vamos a
completar el cuadrado en términos de x
este círculo es x cuadrada menos 8x y
por acá voy a ponerle cuadrada y estoy
dejando un espacio para completar el
cuadrado y para completarlo vamos a
poner la mitad por acá abajo del 8x pero
a su vez
elevaremos al cuadrado la mitad es 4 al
cuadrado 16 y lo agrego de ambos lados
para no alterar la ecuación y ahora
permíteme poner el término de la x
completando el cuadrado y esto sería la
misma cosa que tener
- 4 al cuadrado y luego tenemos más
cuadrada más cuadrada y esto va a ser
igual al 16 es x menos 4 dado que arriba
teníamos menos 8 x hay que respetar el
signo entonces ahora el centro esto nos
va a representar al 4,0
esto es despejando ambas variables y
también tenemos el radio que este base
igual a 4 entonces ahora déjame
dibujarlo o hacer una representación
gráfica del círculo por aquí y primero
voy a dibujar el eje horizontal que es
el eje de las x el eje de las equis y
después por acá el eje vertical que es
el eje de la chaise y ahora dibujando el
centro vamos a dibujar el centro
entonces vamos a tener 1 2 3 4 y por acá
y de al centro 40 y con un radio que le
dará fuerza esto va a lucir algo así
creo que puedo dibujar lo mejor vamos a
dibujar primero la parte superior del
círculo y esta es la primera mitad y
luego tenemos la mitad inferior
ahora hay que pensar en él pero vamos a
pensar en la hipérbole entonces si
nosotros lo miramos así el término x es
positivo por lo que dicha hipérbola va a
abrir hacia la derecha en el dibujo lo
voy a representar y este tipo como de
observaciones
lo hice en otro tipo de sección de
vídeos si quieres darles una revisión
estará perfecto y ahora podríamos
figurarnos donde va a interceptar el eje
de las x entonces mientras la lleva a la
0 nosotros tendríamos que x cuadrada
sobre 9 va a ser igual a 1 y entonces x
será más y menos 3 entonces la hipérbola
va a lucir así entonces es esta parte de
aquí es como el + 3 y ahora vamos a
hacerlo el 3 negativo y abre hacia la
izquierda en este caso entonces ahora el
problema es que ellos nos escriben un
punto y un punto de ellos probablemente
hablan de este punto y de este punto b
así que vamos a pensar en esta pregunta
que nos está diciendo que cómo sería la
tangente común con pendiente positiva
del círculo como de la hipérbola la
tangente común y pensando un poco
en esto si nos están pidiendo una
tangente positiva dicha tangente no va a
tender al círculo por ningún lado dado
que es positiva y con el círculo se
tendría una pendiente negativa entonces
ésta no podría ser dicha tangente no
podría ser la tangente común y entonces
la pregunta que sería es que como lo
haríamos para tener la tangente que
también rozará por el círculo y la
hipérbola a la vez si será por este lado
y dicha región la voy a pintar de color
azul que es donde estará como tentando
sea que aquí habría pasado o podría
pasar una tangente y también podría
pasar por la hipérbola así que de esta
forma de esta forma de alguna manera y
para que veas o visualices como la
hipérbole increíblemente así podrá
apoyarse en alguna línea tangente
nosotros podríamos figurar no la
podríamos figurar que es esta línea de
aquí y dicha línea es asintótica y esto
va a ser siempre pues para que sea
tangente entonces la hipérbola siempre
tendrá una pendiente mayor por este lado
a esta línea y ligeramente mayor o como
para que no se toque ligeramente mayor a
esta línea ascendente entonces si tú
tienes una tan
qué agregar tendrás que tener una
pendiente mayor tendrás que tener una
pendiente más alta pero para cualquier
caso que sea parte del círculo que vaya
hacia afuera de esto entonces tendría
que tener una pendiente menor que la
línea tangente verdad porque va a tener
como que igualar se lee a la tangente
que teníamos y en cualquiera de los
casos que dibujemos pero hagamos esto
más claro tenemos dicha hipérbola la que
actualmente dibujamos entonces esto es
durante todo un periodo y durante esta
parte la hipérbola va a tener una
pendiente más grande porque está como
acercándose a esta línea que está por
exactamente aquí entonces si tomáramos
algo fuera de estar a nosotros si
tomáramos un punto fuera de aquí la
tangente de esta parte del círculo por
acá no va a funcionar puesto que esta
tangente por definición sabemos que en
orden de la hipérbola va a tener una
pendiente menor que está a todo esto a
lo que voy es que como nos podríamos
nosotros ingeniar las cosas para que la
tangente también pasará por
pero la y quizá la única parte de la
hipérbola que debería de ser capaz de
trabajar con esto es la parte baja de la
hipérbole esta parte de por acá entonces
si encontramos una línea tangente puede
estar por aquí puede pasar por la
hipérbola y luego deberíamos encontrar
una tangente común positiva que nos
llevará hacia lo del círculo entonces
déjame dibujar dicha línea y la voy a
dibujar de color rosado y es perfecta
porque es una tangente con pendiente
positiva como es lo que queríamos y
podrá lucir algo así entonces ahora hay
que visualizar esto en el siguiente
vídeo podemos figurar nos figurarnos
como esta línea puede lucir
especialmente cuando podemos construirla
con respecto al círculo pero teniendo
una tangente con esta hipérbola hay que
visualizar y ver entonces nosotros como
podríamos resolverlo